welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with the
explosive finale of stranger things
three turning the Netflix show upside
down it's time to look to the future but
what we could have coming down the line
throughout this video I'll be giving my
thoughts on what could happen in season
four of stranger things and giving the
evidence to support my theories there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't seen season three of stranger
things then I highly recommend that you
turn off now without the way I just want
to give a huge thank you for clicking
this video now let's get into my
stranger things season four predictions
okay so first things first it's a pretty
safe assumption to make that stranger
things fall will take place during
Christmas 1986 the show is centered
around holidays for the past two seasons
with this becoming somewhat of a motif
with Halloween and Independence Day both
playing into the show massively
Christmas is paid lip-service in the
finale by Mike is being the next time
the characters will meet so I can
definitely see this not only being the
time at the show will be set during but
also be the time when Netflix releases
it worldwide what else is so notable
about 1986 is that it's also the year
that the infamous Chernobyl disaster
happened with Russia now playing such a
big part in the show it makes sense that
this would be included and it could be
linked back to their experiments or the
upside down that we've confirmed
throughout the series as the villains
are once again shown in the post-credits
scene and are possessing a demo Gorgon
it makes sense for them to return is the
big bad for the show and perhaps we will
discover in season for that Chernobyl
was an accident involving the country
using a weapon to create a tear in
reality this too ties into the next
prediction which is that the American
and the other cell in the post-credits
scene will be revealed to be hopper I've
already done a full video breaking down
all of the evidence to support this
which you should definitely check out if
you want to know more but the main
points of that hopper eyes of the tear
before the machine explodes he isn't on
the platform when it's destroyed and
Russian Arne refers to hopper as the
American on several occasions the music
at the end of the season is also the
piece that was used when the fake will
was found in season one so it makes
sense that things on what they seem
David Harbor who plays the character is
also sporting a big beard right now so
this could either because he's been
locked in a cell for so long or he's
making cameo as Santa Claus
anyway as 11 no longer has a powers at
the end of season 3 it's a safe bet to
assume that she hasn't been able to look
for him and find the character due to
her inability to track however I do
think that 11 will get her powers back
after coming into contact with the
people who possessed the same ability as
her this was a strong motif of season 2
and I can definitely see it returning so
that L is able to rebuild his psychic
abilities she'll need all the help she
can get if she's to find hopper and
fight the Russians I can definitely see
her teaming up with more psychics to
take them head-on another villain could
come in the form of will whilst I seem
to be the only one with this theory I
think would be cool to see the character
finally taken over by the dark forces
that have had their eyes on him since
season 1 and season 4 could center
around the group trying to pull him back
to the light side as they managed to do
with Billy and the close of the current
Ronin Will has slowly been distancing
himself from his friends with his
interest no longer aligning with theirs
and I think the fact that he now lives
away from them will drive a bigger wedge
that will eventually make him better
about all the things that he's gone
through and allow the dark forces of the
upside down to finally take control of
him this is by far the most dramatic
villain that they could have and the
stakes would really rise by making will
a target the final prediction I don't
think will come in season 4 but rather
season balls set it up for season 5 and
that is the death of 11 the season 4 her
powers are going to be pretty weakened
and if she has to use them she will no
doubt overpower herself and season one
something similar happened with 11 with
the character almost dying due to
everything becoming too much for her
during an interview with Esquire
co-creator Ross defer when discussing
this said 11 was going to sacrifice
herself to save the day that was always
the endgame which to me cements that
eventually at some point L will succumb
to having to use her powers they
obviously weren't going to kill her off
in season 1 as they're not Game of
Thrones
however this comment does highlight that
down the line
planning for her death I can see this
being a huge way to end the show once
and for all and whilst there is
extremely tragic it also ensures that
stranger things goes out with a bang
obviously I loved hear your thoughts on
these predictions and if you agree with
them or not comment below and let me
know and if you enjoy this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of everything you need
to know about the upside-down would you
be linked at the end it covers all the
things we know so far about the dark
realm and it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more I also just
want to let you know that we're giving
away a free copy of Avengers and game to
one lucky winner and all you have to do
is like this video make sure you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on stranger things 3 in the
comment section below the winner will be
chosen at random on August the 10th and
the blu-ray will be shipped down from
the end whoever gets the prize best of
luck to everyone who takes part and I'll
see you next time this is the channel
for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you